the search for survivors is still not
complete in Tennessee after tornadoes
left at least 24 people dead there in
hard-hit putnam county three people are
still unaccounted for the tornado was on
the ground for more than 50 miles that's
one of the longest paths of destruction
in the region's history now this picture
shows a house in Cookeville Tennessee
before the storm our lead national
correspondent David Beck know shows us
the scene now Wow David good morning to
you I still remember the story yesterday
when you said we haven't seen anything
like it seems like that kind of story
continues and Gail look at this now this
is what's left of that home when you
look at it you can understand how three
people died here yesterday Gail we told
you that story of hope and survival
today it's one of grief this is where
the Kim Berlin's lived mom dad and
little baby Sawyer I asked a relative
where in the house was Sawyer's room and
they said right here he just turned 2
last week
[Music]
Clint Pitts shared with us these photos
and videos of his sister Erin a former
school teacher her husband Josh a
mechanical engineer and their only child
Sawyer you say prayer
the Kim Berlin's were devoutly Christian
and Sawyer the grandson of a preacher
loved to direct song with one of his
favorite books the church hymnal there's
something about a family unit going
together that is I don't know I just
can't get it out of my mind as terrible
as it sounds they wouldn't have wanted
to live without each other
it hurts but
[Music]
they're all together
just about four houses down from the Kem
Berlin's is what's left of the Collins
home Matt is a youth minister at a local
church he and his wife were hurt but
they will survive their four-year-old
daughter Hattie was killed and their
youngest child Lainey was critically
injured she turns one today both
families lived in this neighborhood
where homes are little more than trash
piles now 18 people died in Putnam
County Tennessee the National Weather
Service confirms that the tornado here
had winds of more than 175 miles per
hour when you speak to survivors along
this street like Eric grooms who has
nothing left but the foundation of his
home and a carpet that his family sat on
while the closet walls flew away this is
what they say
I just put his hand down said don't
you're not taking these today I mean
literally you take the floor and the
house and leave the people know nobody
can do that we got
nobody four people walked away from the
groom's home which is right across the
street from where the Kim Berlin's live
and I'm standing on the Kimberlin slab
this morning you know I asked the
relatives where where could they have
possibly gone to live and the relatives
think the only space would have been
here the crawlspace under the house
but the reality is because we'll never
know what their final moments were like
nobody will know if they ever had time
to even get here a lot of pain told you
told an incredible story there I don't
even know what to say after listening to
the stories of those family I'm touched
by Clint pizzas brother saying that
they're all together as people I mean
that question lingers how are we also
the ones who survived how are we all
still hear the terrible randomness of it
all
you